foreign
[Music]
Burke professor of Finance at The
Graduate School of Business at Stanford
University and I'm Jules van binsbergen
a finesse professor at the Wharton
School of the University of Pennsylvania
and this is the all else equal podcast
welcome back everybody to one of our
monthly summer episodes well Jules you
know one of the things we like to do in
the summer is to think back what we did
right over the year and what we could
have done better and one of the things
we realized we haven't done which you'd
always wanted to do was to ask our
listeners for suggestions on things they
would like to hear about and so in
particular we would like to encourage
her listeners and the executives that
are listening to tell us what are the
key challenges that you as a business
decision maker are faced with in today's
world what we'd like you to do is go to
the show notes where there'll be a link
to a Google doc where you can fill in
any topic that you would like us to
discuss and the idea is if we already
are experts in the area obviously we can
address the topic but most likely we
will not be experts in the area and what
we'll do is find an expert in the area
get that expert on on the show and have
him or her address the topic yeah so we
would really like to encourage all of
you to go to either the website all else
equalpodcast.com or the show notes and
they'll fill out in the link that is
posted there the topics that you would
like to see addressed and then we will
find a great rest to address that topic
okay so the topic today will be
communication it's something that Jules
and I have thought about it's obviously
a very important topic in business
decision making both communication
formally and informal communication how
do you get your ideas across in an
informal way in a conversation and in a
formal way in a presentation and of
course with respect to those
presentations there is already lots of
good advice out there things like don't
read from your slides when you're
presenting don't have too much
information on a slide don't have too
many slides make sure it fits in the
allotted time slot and things like that
but in this episode we don't want to
spend time on that type of advice what
we wanted to do is invite an expert that
could really go a level deeper somebody
that could really help you get your
message across more effectively and I
think we found the perfect guess for
that so our guest today is Matt Abrams
who is an expert in communication and a
lecturer at The Graduate School of
Business at Stanford he's also the host
of a very successful podcast called
think fast talk smart and he has a new
book think faster talk smarter which
will be published next month
now what I think is interesting about
Matt is no matter the advice he talks
about is advice that isn't particularly
obvious so with that in mind Matt
welcome to the show Matt it's so nice to
have you on I am thrilled to be on your
show okay so Matt I know that you have a
new book it's about business
communication which is a very important
part of business no doubt about it why
don't you just give our listeners a
short intro and what the book's about
absolutely and business communication is
critical I've spent the last 12 years at
the business school teaching strategic
Communication in one of the areas that
has always been deficient in my mind is
that communication that happens in the
moment you know a lot of us know we have
to plan our presentations we have to
prepare our pitches we should set an
agenda for our meetings but if you think
about it most of our communication that
happens day to day in both our
professional and personal lives happens
in the moment somebody asks us a
question we're asked to give feedback we
make a mistake and we have to fix it
that type of spontaneous communication
there hasn't been a lot of
support for teaching people how to do
that better and that's what the new book
think faster talk smarter is really all
about it's Preparing People to speak in
the moment when some of the most
critical most important most connective
conversations happen
so what would you say is the top mistake
people make when they communicate
that's a big question so I think the
number one issue people have when they
communicate is they start from the wrong
place they start by thinking about all
the things they want to say I want you
to know this this and this instead of
thinking what does my audience need to
know it's about your audience's needs
it's not about what you want so it means
we have to think about how can we make
our content maximally relevant Salient
and important for our audience because
if we do that they're going to pay more
attention they're going to care more and
they're more likely to act on what we
say so we have to be audience Centric
that by far is the number one mistake I
see in communication
so Matt I call this the professor's
mistake that is we as professors know
the subject exceptionally well we've
been studying it for 30 years and yet we
cannot really put ourselves in the
position of somebody who has not studied
it and so we always come in at to a
higher level are there any particular
rules of thumb you can use to somehow
know that you're coming in on your
audience at the right level
so Jonathan I don't know what you mean
that professors make mistakes I didn't
know that was possible I make mistakes
all the time and believe me I have two
teenagers they let me know for sure so
absolutely it can be very challenging we
call this the curse of knowledge right
we all know more about what we're
speaking on often than the audiences
we're speaking to and the only antidote
to the curse of knowledge is empathy is
really understanding the needs of the
audience so what I try to do in my
content I've been teaching the same
content for decades is to really meet
with my students one of the very first
things we do is I have them share with
me challenges they have or have had in
their work lives around communication
and that refreshes and reminds me of
where they're at and what knowledge and
challenges they face so my job is to
adjust and adapt my content so part of
it is asking seeking out where is your
audience at now you can do that through
a survey in advance you can do that in
the moment there are ways of
ascertaining if you're presenting at a
conference or you're you're on a panel
ask the moderator ask the people who
have planned the conference they can
help give you that information most of
us especially academic we want to help
people we want people to learn what we
feel is so important and we have to
remind ourselves that people come to us
at very different places and we have to
seek that out and you're right it is a
huge mistake that people make and it has
ramifications not just for the decisions
being made and the information trying to
be transferred but it has a halo effect
where people begin to think that person
is too obtuse they get in the weeds and
that can have negative impact not just
on the interaction now but in the future
so it's very incumbent on us to try to
reduce this curse of knowledge that we
all have agreed now one of the things
you pointed out in this context of
thinking about your audience is this
idea that you have to think about the
cognitive ability of the audience to
understand something obviously you've
been thinking about it for a very long
time you've had a lot of time to to
digest it and now you walking up to
somebody and expecting them to have the
same cognitive ability absolutely so I
talk about this in terms of
accessibility we need to make our
content accessible to our audience and I
use that term very particularly because
I don't want people to dumb things down
or simplify a lot of what we deal with
in business and in our lives in general
is very complex there's Nuance there's
technical detail in some cases
scientific information financial
information we don't want to dumb it
down but we have to find ways to make it
accessible we can use analogies and
comparisons we can tell stories we can
break it into logical reasonable chunks
but this is predicated on exactly what
you said Jonathan we need to understand
where the audience is do they know a lot
do they know a little so that I can
adjust my content accordingly it's not
just about getting the information out
it's about helping your audience to
understand and ultimately do something
with that information so accessibility
is really critical
so Matt one problem that I think you
describe is that people tend to
overburden their audiences when they're
giving them information right so can you
explain in what context that happens
when do people overburden their
audiences and then of course what can
you do yourself to try to avoid that
because I think before you know it
you're doing it without even realizing
it right
absolutely and and we three as academics
are probably certainly guilty or at
least we know colleagues who are guilty
of giving way too much information all
at once so I'd say a few things one we
have to think about pacing of the
information a lot of people because of
anxiety because of excitement because of
limited time they just give a lot of
information all at once and we can feel
overwhelmed so we need to think about
how do we build up to the information so
pacing is one another thing we have to
think about again is level of knowledge
and would it be better for me to give a
primer and some foundational knowledge
to scaffold people so they're more
receptive could I perhaps tell a story
or use an analogy are there things I
could ask people to do in advance of the
communication through pre-reads or have
them watch videos or review certain
information
again most of us are so busy and we're
so focused on what's important to us
that we don't think about the way that
the audience is going to receive the
information and there are things we can
do before they ever meet us and hear
from us they're things we can do while
we're speaking and in fact after the
fact we can follow up and give them more
information or ask them to interact with
us and ask questions so we can do a lot
to help people not feel dumped upon with
all the information we have although of
course in practice there are some limits
to what you propose right in other words
lots of professors ask their students to
pre-read and many of them don't so now
you come in the classroom half the room
has done the pre-readings the other half
hasn't and now you essentially will
either bore people by repeating it or
you will overburden the people if you
give too much information so the other
thing that I was hoping you could
comment on is particularly in a business
decision context as an employee often
you're given this hard situation where
somebody says you get 10 minutes with
person X and so there's no pre-readings
that you can send because they have
absolutely no time to prepare in any way
and they will kick you out of their
office in 10 minutes so how are you
supposed to deal with that situation
so in a classroom context and as a
leader as a manager there have to be
consequences right so if you have
expectations that people will do their
part of the bargain which is I'm going
to make this accessible for you but you
got to do your part of the deal and if
they don't there have to be consequences
so for example if half my class doesn't
do the work I take the class at the
level where I was expecting them to be
and that happens once or twice and then
everybody else starts to catch up in
terms of The Limited timing it's really
about prioritization what's the most
important what are the critical few
things you need to get across that are
relevant for that particular audience so
if I'm talking with a senior leader
about an issue that's important to me I
take his or her perspective and I say
what is most important to them on this
issue and the other thing is you know my
mother has this amazing advice I know
she did not create it but the advice is
this tell the time don't build the clock
a lot of us are clock Builders
especially when talking to senior
leaders where we want them to understand
our logic that got us to to where we are
if they want to know that logic they'll
ask tell the time bottom line up front
be very concise and clear from their
perspective it's hard I get it there's
no magic you just have to really think
about from their perspective and what's
the most critical I love that man if I
could come back to the question of
overload Are there specific things you
can look for in your audience to
indicate when they're not following the
conversation
so there are Clues and cues that you can
pay attention to but you need to be
looking at more than one individual if
you're speaking in front of a group any
one individual signaling may not be as
informative as patterns amongst people
so if you're presenting in front of a
boardroom and they're eight or ten
people and people are looking disengaged
they're looking at their phones they're
distracted so looking at people's
nonverbal presence I'm a big fan of
trying to engage the audience so I am
always asking questions I'm asking
people to think about and give me
examples and in their answers or in the
quality of their questions I am
determining if they're tracking or not
many of us see our goal as communicating
is just getting through our material
that's not helpful if the goal is for
people to actually take in your material
and do something with it you should be
periodically testing and checking to see
if they're tracking and their responses
can be very informative you know I've
gone down a path and then realized
halfway through I've lost people so I
need to backtrack I need to make it more
relevant I need to ask them questions
tell more stories so I can get them
reconnected and re-engaged with the
material so Matt that's my follow-up
question to you let's say and by the way
I assume all of us also passed a
one-on-one conversations yes but let's
say you know one-on-one conversation or
you're in a fun of an audience and it's
clear to you they're not understanding
what you're doing what does it mean to
backtrack what do you do in that
situation
well it depends on the circumstance so
power and Status play a role here so if
you're the business leader if you're the
professor in the classroom you can
literally say it looks like we're going
down a path that is confusing or causing
people a little trouble let's backtrack
so you can literally say time out put on
the brakes let's start now you have to
have some level of authority I think to
pull that off if you are more equally
balanced in terms of power status or
you're uncertain then what I like to do
is I like to turn from monologue to
dialogue I like to get other people
involved so I might puzz and say let's
dive deeper into this Jules I'm curious
where do you see this playing out in
your life or Jonathan have you ever had
a situation like we've just discussed or
we're having the information we just
discussed would have helped so all of a
sudden I'm pulling you in so you're one
more cognitively engaged but two your
responses become very informative to me
and I can then make adjustments but
that's where the ability to speak
spontaneously comes in some of us are so
nervous and so uncomfortable people when
we're off script that doing that becomes
impossible it's so funny that you say
that I noticed that even on the first
day of class when the students
introduced themselves I asked them to
say one minute about themselves and you
can just see that before it's their turn
it's very difficult for them to listen
to anybody else because they're so
nervous about what they're about to say
that they can't even engage meaningfully
and listen to all the other people that
were introduced before them and so I
actually started wondering whether the
introductions are actually sensible for
this reason because they're so busy with
the one minute that they need to speak
that it occupies their mind too much I
think you're exactly right and I'm
smiling as you're asking that question
because with my last name being
Abraham's a B I have always gone first
and so I got used to being called on to
do all those things and you're right
it's very off-putting and you're so
focused on what you're saying you're not
listening here's what I do when I do
self-introductions I actually have
people pair up and then they introduce
their partner and I find that people are
much less stressed when they're
introducing somebody else than when they
are introducing themselves so I
accomplished the same task but I removed
the pressure on individuals now and
you're Building Bridges within the
classroom which is also a side effect
that's very good so Matt can you tell us
a little bit more about your book we
want you when you explain it to deal
with the curse of knowledge which means
that you know way more than we do about
the book and get us the main insights in
there really quickly wow so you're
asking me to think faster and talk
smarter thank you let's see if I can do
this so the origination of this book was
caused by YouTube and people like me the
Deans at the Stanford Business School
came to me and said we have a problem
these amazingly bright smart
well-experienced students are crumbling
under cold calling when a professor cold
calls them and for those listening
that's where the professor says what do
you think or what's your interpretation
on the spot our students couldn't
respond in an articulate well put
together manner so the dean's saying hey
you're the communication guy we know you
do a lot of work in helping people feel
more comfortable and confident speaking
can you help us and that was the origin
of this book so many many years ago I
looked at research from psychology
biology neurology improvisation and came
up with a methodology so the book itself
the first part is all about a six-step
methodology that helps get your mindset
straight and your messaging straight
when you are in a spontaneous speaking
situation and then the second part of
the book to really help people digest it
are six very specific spontaneous
speaking situations that people find
challenging answering questions giving
feedback making apologies introducing
people Small Talk these are things that
we find challenging so the hope of the
book as with everything I teach tries to
be very practical and tactical while
based in theory to help people feel more
comfortable and confident in those
situations so it started with the cold
call issue issue and then grew into more
generic spontaneous speaking and it's
all about mindset and messaging Now Matt
I know you have strong feelings about
scripted presentations right well you've
helped me explain that already Jonathan
but this notion of cognitive load you
can think of our brains as CPUs for
computers it's not a Perfect Analogy but
for the case of the argument I'm about
to make it serves well so a computer
processor has only so much bandwidth
right and the more applications and
tools that you're running simultaneously
actually all of them run a little slower
they're not as efficient your brain in
some ways works the same way so if I
create a script and memorize that script
part of my mind while I'm communicating
is comparing what I intended to say
versus what I'm saying in other words
I'm using bandwidth precious bandwidth
to be comparing judging and evaluating
which means I have less to focus on what
I'm actually doing so memorizing action
really makes us less likely to be fluent
and more likely to forget what we want
to say simply because we're taxing
ourselves too much so there are many
reasons why writing out exactly what you
want to say makes sense for example
you've got a lot of detail and you want
to see how it all fits you're a
non-native speaker in the language
you're speaking and you want to make
sure you've got the vocabulary down
there are lots of reasons to script
things out but then go one extra step
create an outline or some key talking
points from that script and from that
work so you have a little more
flexibility to move among your points so
you're not so wedded to exactly what
you're saying what I do and some of the
people I coach some of our colleagues
love this technique once I create a
script I then create an outline and from
that outline I generate a list of
questions and all I do is remind myself
of those questions I know the answers so
when I speak when I lecture I am simply
answering unasked questions of my
audience and the benefit of this the
added benefit one less cognitive load is
put on me but second we tend to be more
conversational and engaging when we
answer questions than we just go through
materials so all of a sudden I'm
engaging the audience more which is
certainly beneficial so memorizing
scripting can be very dangerous and can
actually bring about the very things
you're trying to avoid so with respect
to those questions what do you do with
those questions do you just have them on
a piece of paper in front of you do you
put them on slides so that you go
through them and remind yourself or do
you memorize those questions of the
three things you mentioned the first two
are things I'll do I don't believe in
memorizing so for example if I have a
slide deck the title of my slides are
simply the questions I'm going to answer
there's actually some research that says
slide titles that are sentences or
questions are more engaging and more
remembered than just sort of phrases so
I'm helping my audience and I'm helping
myself another thing I do is I'll have
them on a note page and when I preview
and previewing what you're going to say
to an audience just like having an
agenda is really important I just say
today we're we're going to discuss three
questions and I label those questions I
put them out there that helps me
remember them because I've just spoken
them and sometimes I forget and I'll ask
my audience I'll say hey now that we've
covered the first question what was the
second thing we were going to cover and
I make it a test of them but in fact
they're helping me remember so I try not
to memorize because any form of
memorization affects our cognitive load
so max let me give you an example of a
stress that I have when I'm teaching or
when I'm giving a lecture because like
you I don't memorize
it's that I will forget to say something
very important
and that of course it takes a cognitive
load because what I'm worrying about oh
I mustn't forget to say this so do you
have any advice on how to deal with that
so depending on what it is and how
critical it is you might say before we
proceed I want to make sure I cover this
point I'm not a big fan of saying oh I
forgot or I can't believe I didn't cover
this because then that takes your
audience out of the flow that you're in
and now they're observing your thought
process which distracts them from paying
attention so I might just say hey one
last thing we have to cover or before we
move on to this next thing I want to
review this in a different way so I try
to fold it in I might make a note of it
when I teach right now in front of me I
have a notebook I might write something
down just to remind myself so I take the
burden off of me having to keep it in
mind and I offload it and write it down
knowing I can come back to it the last
thing I'll say there is your audience
only knows what you tell them they don't
know what you did not tell them that you
intended to so sometimes we think this
is absolutely critical but when you
reflect from the audience's perspective
maybe it's not as critical or at least
as critical at this moment so it might
be that I just let it go and say next
time I'm going to catch that up or in
the notes I send out afterwards if it
truly is critical I would just go back
to it without making a big deal
so when it comes to communicating an
important message right there's a choice
that as a communicator you have which is
you can try to artificially boost the
importance of the message that you have
by exaggerating it
now the question is under what
circumstances do you think you want to
boost a message that way are there
circumstances when you do or do not want
to do it or do you think it's always bad
to go for the exaggeration strategy so
you have to be very careful with how you
exaggerate first if you exaggerate you
should do it purposely not just out of
habit or reflex you should be thinking
I'm going to really accentuate this here
for this specific purpose a lot of us do
it just out of habit or because we think
in the short term it's going to be very
helpful without thinking about the
long-term consequences so it is a tool
in the toolkit it's not one I like to
use a lot because it carries a lot of
consequence to it and it can look like
you're just trying to be effusive or
kissing up but it is a tool in the
toolkit okay man one last question now
that you've heard the show what advice
do you have for us about our
miscommunication skills
well I have always been impressed with
your communication and I really like the
way you both play off of each other I
think the bigger challenge that all of
us face when we have coordinated
communication as you do as co-hosts it's
how do you figure out when to step in
and step up and when to step back and
listen and it's hard to do and you do it
very well but there have been times
where we can misstep and that's the
biggest challenge because you look
uncoordinated here's where I see this
happen a lot and you might have seen it
as in working in the context you do I
help a lot of entrepreneurs a lot of our
students pitch and they'll pitch with
partners and when it comes to q a
somebody will ask a very reasonable
question and they spend 30 seconds to a
minute looking you're gonna who's gonna
I mean right there's this moment of
coordination that ruins their
credibility if one of them would just
step up and say I'm going to take the
question or you know that's a better
question for you then all of a sudden
that that issue of coordination looks
well handled and bolsters credibility
rather than taking away from it very
good well Matt that was really
fascinating thank you so much for coming
on the show it was great to have you
thank you it was great great to be back
with all of you continued success on
your podcast and thank you for having me
and letting me talk about my new book
thanks for listening to the all else
equal podcast
please leave us a review at Apple
podcasts we love to hear from our
listeners and be sure to catch our Next
Episode by subscribing or following our
show wherever you listen to your
podcasts for more information episodes
visit all else equalpodcast.com or
follow us on LinkedIn the all else equal
podcast is a production of Stanford
University's Graduate School of Business
and is produced by University FM
foreign
[Music]